non ce la faccio più Questo è un inferno
Ma come faccio a rilassarmi sono i
bambini che mi strillano nelle orecchie
basta la mia pazienza è un limite e lei
la madre di questi bambini Sì sono io
c'è qualche problema Il problema sono i
suoi figli maleducati E rispettosi
perché ti hanno fatto stanno gridando da
stamattina mi sta scoppiando la testa
signora sono bambini giocano Sì
divertono seta se questo loro modo di
giocare vi consiglio di tenerli a casa
invece di portarvi qui a disturbare
tutta la spiaggia venite qua e chiedete
subito scusa alla signora Io le loro
scuse non le voglio non gelato invece
era buona approvando a corrompermi con
un gelato questo non è un gelato
qualunque Questo è lo stecco Gourmet di
Coop No guardi Mi dispiace a me piace
solo pistacchio e allora deve provare Lo
stecco con gelato al pistacchio
cioccolato bianco e granella di
pistacchio Non so perché per colpa dei
suoi figli mi è venuto un calo di
zuccheri
Allora Beh in effetti è buono così buono
che sono riuscita ad addolcirla Sì
infatti Senta ma il piccoletto Come si
chiama Nicola perché Nicola vieni qui Se
non la smetti di urlare sai che fine
fanno questi gelati e li prendo tutti io
[Musica]